[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent à l on
soit vient des lignes aujourd'hui on a
une gauche extrêmement sujet de maths et
la société fonctionne ajouté
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
des crimes inexcusable pour la
république les mots d' emmanuel macron
pour dénoncer à la répression sanglante
du 17 octobre 1961 à paris le président
qui participait également à une
cérémonie officielle commémorant les 60
ans de ce massacre qui a visé des
algériens on en parle dès le début de ce
journal
[Musique]
samedi de mobilisation pour les gilets
jaunes mais aussi pour les gens qui
passent sanitaire dans toute la france
aujourd'hui un mouvement qui reprend son
souffle pour dénoncer la hausse du prix
du carburant les gilet jaune était donc
de retour sur les ronds-points pour
dénoncer cette augmentation du prix de
l'essence
[Musique]
nous ferons un point sur la situation en
russie où la crise sanitaire inquiète en
cause une hausse du nombre de décès liés
aux copies de 19 le pays dénombre
désormais plus de 1000 morts qui vont
nous enterrer
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20 heures
soixante ans après le massacre du 17
octobre 1961 à paris la france fait un
pas dans la reconnaissance de cette
tragédie dans un communiqué de l'elysée
le président dénonce des crimes
inexcusable pour la république un
communiqué transmis après que le chef de
l'état a observé une minute de silence
mais aussi déposé une gerbe lors d'une
cérémonie officielle sur le pont de
bezons il est d'ailleurs le premier
président à participer à une journée de
colère où ration du 17 octobre 1961
ce jour là plusieurs algériens
manifester pacifiquement une
mobilisation pour dénoncer un couvre-feu
discriminatoire puisque à imposer aux
français musulmans d'algérie selon des
historiens alors d'une sanglante
répression plusieurs dizaines d'entre
eux ont donc été tué sous l'autorité du
préfet de police de l'époque maurice
papon écoutez ya le communiqué de
l'elysée
le président a reconnu les faits les
crimes commis cette nuit là sous
l'autorité de maurice papon sont
inexcusables pour la république la
france regarde toute son histoire avec
lucidité et reconnaît les
responsabilités clairement établie elle
le doit d'abord et avant tout à elle
même à toutes celles et ceux que la
guerre d'algérie et son cortège de
crimes commis de tous côtés ont meurtris
dans leur chair et dans leur âme elle le
doit en particulier à sa jeunesse pour
qu'elle ne soit pas enfermé dans les
conflits de mémoire et construisent dans
le respect et la reconnaissance de
chacun son avenir vous lisez c'est donc
un pas de plus dans la reconnaissance de
ce massacre emmanuel macron est allé
plus loin que françois hollande qui a en
2012 avait parlé d'une je cite sanglante
répression le chef de l'état qui est
aussi le premier à participer à une
cérémonie officielle commémorant ce 17
octobre 1961 et pour mead kaki le
fondateur de l'association mémorielle
les oranje cela n'est pas suffisant
c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
qu'un président de la république
française se déplacent sur les lieux du
crime et ça nous le saluons
véritablement c'est vrai qu'il faut le
saluer cette affaire mais quand on va
dans les lieux de crime alors il faut
nommer les véritables criminels c'est à
dire le crime d'état et c'est dans ce
sens que je pense que il s'est arrêté au
milieu de la route monsieur macro et il
faut qu'il aille jusqu'au bout pour
désigner pas seulement maurice papon
j'ai bien entendu maurice papon c'est
trop facile de dire que c'est
des cons je dire des actions inexcusable
un drame et non c'est plus et plus loin
que ça c'est à dire que maurice papon
est sous l'autorité du gouvernement et
donc
la responsabilité du gouvernement de
l'époque est engagé et c'est dans ce
sens que c'est un crime d'état il faut
que monsieur emmanuel macron va encore
plus loin
autre cérémonie d'hommage aujourd'hui
rendu cette fois à samuel pâtit cela
fait un an que le professeur d'histoire
géographie a été sauvagement assassiné
en pleine rue l'année dernière pour
avoir montré des caricatures du prophète
mohamed à sa classe il enseignait alors
dans un établissement de
conflans-sainte-honorine dans le
département des yvelines plusieurs
hommages lui ont été rendus et notamment
dans le collège du bois donne où ils
travaillent et le premier ministre jean
castex mais aussi le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel bancaires
étaient présents dans la matinée ils ont
même dévoilé une plaque commémorative
dans l'entrée du ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour lui rendre
hommage
le nom de samuel pâtit un écho dans
toute la france mais aussi dans le monde
entier
monsieur le professeur vous rejoignez
par votre exemple les hommes et les
femmes illustres qui ont fait l'école de
la république notre école est
aujourd'hui au nom de l'institution tout
entière nous vous rendons hommage rendre
hommage à samuel pâtit c'est rendre
hommage à la république
et rendre hommage à la république et
avec elle à nos libertés fondamentales
dont elle est la garantie autant que la
condition
c'est d'abord la défendre avec une
inébranlable volonté la nation tout
entière
doivent lutter pierre à pied dans le
monde en europe et bien sûr à
l'intérieur du territoire national
contre le terrorisme islamiste contre le
terrorisme sous toutes ses formes
nouvelles journées de mobilisation pour
les gilets jaunes dans toute la france
dès gilet jaune de retour sur les
ronds-points pour dénoncer la hausse du
prix de l'essence cela avait d'ailleurs
été l'une de leurs revendications dès le
début de leur mouvement en 2018 des
gilet jaune qui aux côtés des opposants
au pass and i ter ont aussi manifesté à
paris où l'on retrouve notre reporter
n'a déjà de dera sach
est une manifestation qui avait pour but
de donner un second souffle au gilet
jaune trois ans après la naissance du
mouvement
la situation est quasiment revenue à la
case départ pour les gilet jaune et pour
cause elle est prix du carburant sont
aujourd'hui aussi haut qu'il l'était il
ya trois ans c'est d'ailleurs ce qui les
a fait fait descendre dans les rues et
autour des ronds points à ce moment là
alors à cela s'ajoute à présent une
hausse importante du prix de
l'électricité et du gaz à ce sujet je
vous propose d'écouter deux figures
emblématiques des gilet jaune
jérôme rodrigues et faouzi l'éloge la
manif de cesse d'enfler après il est
clair que c'est un appel sur le national
c'est à dire car beaucoup de ronds
points qui seront repris pas mal
d'autres manifestations moi même j'avais
lancé un appel à ce que les gens se
regroupent autour de chez eux et non pas
venir sur paris pour peut-être avoir un
phénomène médiatique beaucoup plus ample
et sur un maillage territorial et
montrer que c'est l'ensemble des
français qui sont en colère je tiens à
préciser a rappelé que la naissance des
gilets jaunes vient aussi pour
principalement de la province car ce
sont eux qui sont le plus impacté
aujourd'hui avec la hausse des prix de
l'énergie des carburants et des cours
des colis première nécessité tout le
monde dans son quotidien est capable de
voir et de constater les augmentations
continues sur les produits de première
nécessité ce qu'on avait demandé dès le
début on peut voir que tout a augmenté
concernant les énergies tout augmente à
leur bon vouloir donc il ya des vraies
excuses alors que pourtant pas remis
parmi ces prix par exemple je prends
l'exemple d'un litre de gasoil 80
centimes va pour l'état dans les taxes
donc je pense qu'ils auraient pu réduire
aussi leurs bénéfices dessus parce que
ça devient du bénéfice à 80 centimes
quand on paye le prix d'un litre 1 euro
60 1 euros 50 donc j'estime que c'est
abusé de prendre les gens comme ça de
haut et de se dire que il ya des gens
qui sortent depuis trois ans et en fin
de compte on en a rien à faire on les
écoute pas et pire pour les réprimandes
donc voilà il était important de revenir
comme d'art comme on était là tous les
samedis mais avec une vraie visibilité
de dire que voilà les choses album
changé que par les citoyens parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un un parti
politique ou une opposition à part les
citoyens qui peut essayer de nous
permettre de bénéficier de ce qu'on
réclame c'est à dire pouvoir vivre
dignement vous l'aurez compris au sein
du mouvement des gis les jeunes beaucoup
espèrent une reprise de la contestation
de la même ampleur qu'en 2018 et pour
cause il estime que la situation s'est
bien plus dégradée aujourd'hui une
reprise de leur mouvement après un
essoufflement due à la crise sanitaire
qui pourrait avoir des répercussions sur
la stratégie du gouvernement mais aussi
sur la présidentielle écoutez à ce
propos antonin peschard avocat au
barreau de paris et josé espinosa gilet
jaune
on a un élément déclencheur qui a permis
à ce mouvement absolument légitime de
reprendre de l'activité
la question qui se pose c'est bon il a
été suspendu manifestement c'est à cause
de la crise sanitaire maintenant que on
entrevoit la fin de la crise et
conclusion à cet élément déclencheur
peut-être que le gouvernement devrait
revoir l'ordre de ses priorités
parce que d'annoncer en sortie de crise
sanitaire après un an et demi
confinement et un quoi qu'il en coûte
qui va provoquer un retour de bâton
assez violent au niveau des finances
publiques au lieu d'annoncer la réforme
des retraites est de
montrer qu'au bout d'un an et demi il
est toujours dans le même état d'esprit
c'est à dire de n'écouter personne que
lui même je pense qu'il aurait mieux
fait à ce moment là d'essayer d'apaiser
les choses et de mettre tout le monde
autour d'une table je pense que la
situation est pire qu'avant est ce que
nous avons aujourd'hui des millions de
pauvres de plus c'est le résultat de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par macron
c'est qu'il est rappelé ouvrit la
population vous savez que les salariés
ont perdu 16 % de leur salaire à cause
de la mise en chômage technique et donc
il ya des difficultés supplémentaires
qui sont intervenus et je pense qu'avec
le passé nanterre il s'est mis à dos 12
gentil beau tout poli et donc tout cela
c'est qu'il ya un mécontentement qui
gronde encore plus fortement qu avant et
qui va certainement se manifester lors
des élections présidentielles
en russie nouveau record de décès dus
aux copies de 19 le pays enregistre
désormais plus de 1000 morts aujourd'hui
pour les autorités fédérales les régions
doivent prendre les mesures sanitaires
nécessaires en fonction de leur
situation ont fait le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou verhaeghe aux
fans
mille deux décennies que v 19
enregistrée aujourd'hui en russie il
s'agit d'un nouveau record de mortalité
depuis le début de la pandémie le nombre
de décès quotidiens n'ayant jamais
jusqu'à ce jour dépassé le seuil des
1000 les autorités fédérales estime que
c'est aux régions de décider quelles
mesures prendre en fonction de leur
situation sur place
bien sûr une certaine expérience a été
acquise au cours des deux dernières
années environ l'ensemble du système
médical a été mobilisée et évidemment il
existe désormais un plus grand nombre de
technologies et de protocoles de
traitement ainsi que des capacités
accrues au niveau des infrastructures
par conséquent tant que l'infrastructure
sanitaire d'une région donnée n'est pas
submergés et reste en état de
fonctionnement cela restera ainsi
[Musique]
mais bien sûr il est nécessaire
d'intensifier considérablement le
travail visant à expliquer la nécessité
de la vaccination
et dans les régions où la situation
approche du point critique c'est très
simple lorsque les capacités du système
de santé régional ne permettent plus
d'apporter une assistance aux patients
en entrant
alors les autorités en se fondant sur
leurs pouvoirs spéciaux prennent
différentes décisions
la situation moscou est considérée comme
la plus compliquée de toutes les régions
russes le maire de moscou sergueï
sobianine reconnaît que la nouvelle
vague de couronnes au virus est
difficile avec une dynamique très forte
à moscou malheureusement on relève une
augmentation significative des nouveaux
cas de co vide 20 30% par semaine il
s'agit d'un taux très élevés
en plus du respect des règles sanitaires
il existe deux autres axes de prévention
et de contrôle du coc vide il s'agit des
tests de masse qui doivent être
effectués à temps afin d'identifier le
patient et d'assurer son isolement et
son traitement en temps opportun
et la seconde méthode c'est évidemment
la vaccination
plus de 33000 nouveaux cas de
coronavirus ont été détectés en russie
ces dernières 24 heures moscou de
nombreux plus de 6500 nouveaux malades
suivis par saint pétersbourg avec plus
de 3000 contamination dont soumise à un
confinement strict la nouvelle zélande
apprend désormais à vivre avec le
collègue 19 alors que le nombre de
contamination augmente la campagne
vaccinale connais tel un coup
d'accélérateur les précisions d'adrien
fonteneau
réquisition d'un boeing 787
organisation d'un festival national
cette fois c'est sûr la nouvelle zélande
accélère sa campagne de vaccination on
veut juste une bonne ambiance une bonne
atmosphère on a de la musique pour la
journée de la nourriture gratuite tout
pour encourager la vaccination est
rassuré ceux qui pourraient être effrayé
par le vaccin
une recette gagnante mené par sa
première ministre justin d'ardeur ce
samedi la nouvelle zélande a même établi
un nouveau record national avec près de
130 mille injection en une journée car
dans le même temps les cas recensés
quotidiennement repartent aussi à la
hausse avec des niveaux de contamination
similaires au mois d'août dernier et
l'arrivée du variant delta la fin d'un
confinement strict et le revirement de
stratégie sanitaire se sont imposés au
pays avec cette explosion de cas et avec
le variant delta l'objectif de zéro co
vide est incroyablement difficile à
tenir une seule restriction ne suffisent
pas à l'atteindre rapidement même avec
les restrictions à long terme que nous
avons imposées nous n'avons
manifestement pas atteint le niveau zéro
mais ce n'est pas un problème
l'élimination du virus était importante
parce que nous n'avions pas de vaccin
maintenant nous en avons donc nous
pouvons changer la façon dont nous
faisons les choses et si la nouvelle
zélande est un des pays qui vaccinent le
plus vite sa population la route est
encore longue avant d'atteindre
l'immunité collective sur l'île seuls
54% de la population est pleinement
vacciner
la mission de l'onu en haïti prolongé de
neuf mois à la chine et les puissances
occidentales sont finalement parvenus à
trouver un compromis au dernier jour du
mandat du vih l'admission politiques de
l'onu en haïti les précisions de grâce
taya avec hélène basculer
une décision prise in extremis qui met
fin au bras de fer entre les etats-unis
et la chine 9 mois de prolongation de la
mission politique des nations unies en
haïti alors que les états unis proposent
est un an de reconduction contre six
mois imposé par le veto chinois un
compromis trouvé le jour même de la fin
du mandat d' hélène lalime l'émissaire
de l'onu en haïti
comme nous le savons tous l'année
dernière a été particulièrement
turbulente en haïti en renouvelant le
mandat du bureau intégré des nations
unies en haïti nous avons contribué à
garantir que l'onu puisse poursuivre ses
efforts est essentielle pour soutenir
les institutions démocratiques et la
planification des élections renforcer
l'état de droit et promouvoir la
stabilité
à la demande des membres du conseil dont
la chine le projet requiert du
secrétaire général qu'il procède à une
évaluation du mandat de la mission de
l'onu en haïti et notamment qu'il
détermine si et comment le mandat doit
être adaptée pour répondre aux
difficultés actuelles d'haïti
dénommé been eu cette mission politique
de l'onu qui existe depuis 2010 neuf
devait expirer ce vendredi son objectif
renforcer la stabilité politique réduire
la violence et protéger les droits
humains la chine invoque un argent
gaspillé et une inaction de la mission
des nations unies en haïti pour
justifier son refus
mais la raison véritable pourrait bien
être la question taïwanaise en septembre
à l'assemblée générale des nations unies
plusieurs états ont réaffirmé
reconnaître taiwan parmi ceux-ci belize
le paraguay et surtout haïti qui a des
relations diplomatiques avec lille
depuis 1956 une position insoutenable
pour la chine
des années de pratique ont complètement
démontré que l'onu et ses membres ont
tous admis qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
chine dans le monde et que taiwan et la
partie indivisible de la chine ils ont
pleinement admis les exercices de
souveraineté de la chine sur taïwan
le veto de la chine sur la reconduction
du mandat du bim eu pour est ainsi
s'apparenter à une forme de représailles
envers haïti une bataille de
reconnaissance internationale au
détriment d'une situation sur le terrain
qui se détériore violence instabilité
politique avant et depuis la mort de
jouvenel moïse avec des élections qui
n'auront pas lieu avant le deuxième
semestre 2022
dès le 1er janvier prochain la france
prend la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne la question du recours au
mécénat d'entreprise privée revient sur
le devant de la scène plusieurs ong
pointent du doigt à conflit d'intérêts
concernant le contrat signé par paris
avec notamment deux entreprises et
appelle à mettre fin à cette pratique
les explications en images
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
nous considérons aussi la possibilité
d'une compensation carbone intégrale des
émissions liées à la présidence en
faisant appel à des énergéticiens
français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si la france a besoin de nourriture
boisson moyens de transport ou tout
autre type de biens et services durant
sa présidence de l'ue eux elle doit se
les procurer de façon normale et payer
un juste prix pour cela ces pratiques
louches de sponsoring doivent prendre
fin
[Musique]
une nouvelle fois la présidence
tournante du conseil de l'ue eux
risquent de se trouver instrumentalisée
au profit des intérêts des grandes
entreprises avec la coopération active
du gouvernement français
[Musique]
le royaume-uni bouleversé par le meurtre
de david amess le député britannique
poignardé vendredi lors d'une permanence
parlementaire toute la classe politique
et la société britannique multiplie
gestes démultiplier ges tv hommage
aujourd'hui boris johnson s'est même
rendu sur les lieux où un mémorial de
fortune a été édifié maxime abers
une classe politique divisée mais unis
ce samedi dans le deuil et la
consternation
boris johnson et le leader de
l'opposition qui re starmer côte-à-côte
déposent une gerbe de fleurs au mémorial
improvisé en l'honneur de david haye
mais ce parlementaire de 69 ans
assassiné alors qu'il discutait avec des
électeurs à l'oeil en six communes de la
côte est de l'angleterre
sous le choc le premier ministre a tenu
à saluer un homme d'action suivi par de
nombreuses personnalités politiques
inquiètent du danger qui les entoure
brych nappe est une escroquerie david
était un homme qui croyait passionnément
en ce pays en son avenir nous avons
perdu aujourd'hui un excellent
fonctionnaires un ami et un collègue
très aimé et nos pensées vont
aujourd'hui à sa femme ses enfants et sa
famille
david lui même était un homme du peuple
il a été tué en faisant un travail qui
les met en servant ses propres électeurs
en tant que membre élu de la démocratie
un mais bien sûr de tels actes sont
absolument condamnable et nous ne
pouvons pas laisser cela à entraver le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
c'est en tant que membre du parlement
nous voulons être accessible et
abordable
mais récemment il ya eu de plus en plus
d'abus violent que ce soit sur les
médias sociaux que ce soit pour moi ou
d'autres parlementaires qui reçoivent
des menaces de mort devant l'église de
belles fesses ou le député s'est fait
poignardé à plusieurs reprises les
habitants des environs sont venus
déposer carte de condoléances et
bouquets de fleurs sur place c'est la
stupéfaction
j'ai l'impression d'avoir perdu un
membre de ma famille des 32 des membres
de ma famille j'ai le coeur brisé mon
coeur est brisé pour sa famille et ses
enfants et pour tous ces thèmes que nous
aimons profondément
il était partout hier a été une journée
tellement dévastatrice nous n'avons pas
de choses comme ça qui arrive par ici
c'était un homme tellement bon vraiment
il a fait beaucoup pour tout le monde il
ne repoussait personnes depuis ce
vendredi une personne a été interpellée
un britannique d'origine somalienne âgé
de 25 ans et dont la motivation serait
lié à l'extrémisme islamiste selon le
journal the guardian il partagerait les
mêmes données qu une personne signalée
au programme de lutte contre la
radicalisation
l'enquète a été confiée à la direction
antiterroriste ce drame rappelle le
meurtre d'une autre parlementaire john
cox assassiné en 2016 par un extrémiste
de droite il relance le débat autour de
la sécurité des élus à l'époque le
budget consacré avait été revu largement
à la hausse passant de 200 milles à 5
millions de livres priti patel la
ministre de l'intérieur a d'ores et déjà
annoncé de nouvelles mesures pour
améliorer les dispositifs de sécurité
autour des parlementaires
en
2011 le conflit entre le parti
indépendantiste de letea et les
gouvernements espagnol et français
prenaient fin depuis jeudi une série de
conférences est organisé à
saint-sébastien et bayonne pour célébrer
une date à laquelle a pris fin un
affrontement qui aura fait plus de 800
morts et dont il reste encore quelques
cicatrices reportage de maxime abers et
jordi d'amauri
c'est un havre de paix symbolique dans
l'histoire du pays basque il y a dix ans
le conflit opposant le groupe
indépendantiste eta à l'espagne et à la
france prenait fin ici dans le palais
d'aiete à saint-sébastien ce 17 octobre
2011 une délégation internationale
emmenée par kofi annan rencontrait des
membres de letea des politiques
françaises et espagnoles mais aussi des
membres de la société civile basque et
les acteurs du processus de paix le pays
basque sortait d'une dernière tentative
de négociation entre l'état espagnol
heures et l'état et le thé à qui avait
échoué et devoirs de voir toutes ces
personnalités internationales à venir au
pays basque avec pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de ce conflit
l'ensemble des acteurs politiques
des territoires historiques présent à y
était ça avait de nouveau
impulser un espoir parmi eux brian
purines médiateur reconnu qui a déjà
oeuvré en afrique du sud et en irlande
du nord en partie grâce au travail de
ces hommes de l'ombre pour la première
fois le monde évoque ouvertement un
conflit que madrid et paris ont du mal à
assumer
il fallait ouvrir des voies de
communication entre les différents
groupes et partis du conflit c'était mon
rôle
tout
cela a contribué à ce que le thé a et la
gauche indépendantiste changent leur
agenda politique
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et c'est ce qui
a fait du pays basque ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
trois jours après la conférence d'aiete
le groupe indépendantiste annonce dans
un communiqué mettre un terme à un demi
siècle de lutte armée
le début d'une décennie de stabilité
malgré la difficile réconciliation et
chemin
la seule chose qui reste problématique
aujourd'hui c'est le statut de victime
et la question du pardon et de la
réconciliation
blessures que les partis politiques
utilisent parfois à des fins électorales
y est
le gros mâle moi je dirais de ce
processus là aujourd'hui il ya cette
guerre de récits permanente qui
n'empêche pas de manière sereine
d'appréhender la complexité de ce
conflit là on ne construira pas les
réelles garanties du non-renouvellement
de l'histoire si on n'est pas capable
dans ce territoire de permettre que tous
les récits puisse exister et cohabiter
aujourd'hui certaines cicatrices ne sont
toujours pas refermées
la polémique autour du sort réservé aux
anciens membres de l' eta prisonnier
politique ou exil est toujours
d'actualité mais la société civile
espère recréer un nouvel élan retrouvé
l'esprit d'aiete et construire une
feuille de route pour les dix prochaines
années
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain journal
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
le résultat d'un vol peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]